le week-end dans la vallée de la
Maurienne les soulèvements de la terre
ont une nouvelle fois organisé une
manifestation interdite 12 de nos
gendarmes ont été blessés et je souhaite
ici saluer leur courage et leur
professionnalisme face à des personnes
qui cherchaient la confrontation aucune
cause monsieur le député ne justifie que
l'on blesse des policiers ou des
gendarmes
je voudrais rappeler que cette
manifestation était interdite confirmée
à deux reprises par la justice de notre
pays que malgré cette manifestation à
interdite 2000 à 3000 personnes dont
malheureusement des élus de la
République ont bravé c'est interdiction
ne respectant ni le droit ni la décision
des choses de juger et que le travail
fait par les policiers légendes ont
permis
350 contrôle d'armes et d'armes de poing
qui pouvaient blesser voir tuer les
policiers et les gendarmes grâce au
travail de nos services de renseignement
et grâce aux autorités italiennes que de
réussir remercier une centaine
d'éléments radicaux venus d'Italie on
peut être bloqué à la frontière et
malgré cela malheureusement deux jours
d'affrontement une autoroute occupée une
voie ferrée coupée et de nombreux
personnels des services publics qui sont
effectivement devant la haine et la
alors oui à la demande du Président de
la République et de la première ministre
demain matin je présenterai au Conseil
des ministres le décret de dissolution
les soulevant de la terre
[Applaudissements]